-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
and now, we're going
to get to the news.
President Biden
last night delivered
his first
State of the Union address
and Chuck Schumer could not
figure out when to clap.
[ Booing ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-The American Rescue Plan
helped working people.
-It's like every white guy
at a hip hop show.
[ Laughter ]
"You're clapping
on the ones and threes,
Richard!"
[ Laughter ]
During President Biden's
State of the Union address
last night,
several members of Congress
wore blue and yellow
in solidarity with Ukraine,
though I'm not sure everybody
understood the assignment.
[ Laughter ]
During last night's speech,
Republican Congresswomen
Marjorie Taylor Greene
and Lauren Boebert heckled
and booed President Biden
on several occasions.
In their defense,
he is, technically,
the manager.
[ Hesitant laughter ]
And that, technically,
was a joke.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Technically.
[ Laughter ]
During President Biden's
State of the Union address
last night,
he accidentally said "Iranian,"
instead of "Ukrainian."
[ Laughter ]
Well,
in a speech where he had
to pronounce Volodymyr Zelenskyy
and Ketanji Brown Jackson,
something had to give.
[ Laughter and applause ]
According to a new poll,
71% of Americans
who watched President Biden's
State of the Union address
had a positive reaction
to the speech,
but let's be honest --
everyone who would've had
a negative reaction
was watching "Yellowstone."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
New York has the highest
median rent price
for a one-bedroom apartment
in the country.
Well, yeah, but it's all
about location, location...
[ Train screeching, rumbling ]
[ Laughter ]
...location.
And, finally,
Major League Baseball
announced yesterday
that they are
postponing their
March 31st Opening Day
and canceling
the first two series
of regular season baseball,
after the league could not reach
a bargaining agreement
with its players' union,
which is bad news for the Mets
because the regular season is
the only one they got.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!